i am here with the utterly amazing
natalie portman who has written her
first
children's book natalie portman's fables
and joining us to talk about it is our
resident reviewer
none other than jonah larson
hi jonah hi jerome so excited to see you
again
and i'm really excited to review ms
portman's book
so nice to meet you i'm so impressed by
everything you're doing like
this is so incredible and thank you so
much for taking time with the book i'm
so happy to meet you
thank you miss portman i'm really happy
that you enjoy my work and makes you
feel really good
but i enjoyed and loved your book for
a plethora of reasons we added a classic
and modernized twist to
the fables that everyone knows and loves
with the three little pigs
and i read the book and then my dad read
it to me
and then i read it to my little sister
mercy and i loved it more
each and every time and my favorite
story was the three little pigs and it
was also my sister's favorite
because she loved that the big bad wolf
was a girl
because usually in fairy tales you think
that
um female character always needs to be
rescued or isn't as strong
so she thought it was pretty cool to see
that the big bad wolf was a girl
but i also just loved the classic
messages of slowing down
and taking your time and doing things
right and appreciating the things that
we sometimes overlook
and we need to be grateful for like our
family
our friends and also the earth
and also i wanted to really i can really
relate to you
and how you wrote that special message
to your mom in the back of your book
because my mom's my favorite too
and for all of those reasons
i'm rating miss portman's fables
5 out of 5 crochet loops
thank you so much i am so honored i'm
like
teared up this is so meaningful to me
that you read it and
and took it in that way and processed it
you're so incredible that you
i don't know the way you the way you
express yourself is so so impressive too
i have to show you something that's so
cool look
it's a jonah doll is it just like me
we're twins
and i'm gonna have these on my website
as kids
and but this one right here i'm gonna
auction and 100
of the proceeds are going to go to my
library in ethiopia
so i'm super excited well jonah can we
put that up on our website
also for your auction
would do that thank you so much you're
that's
thank you so much that's one of the
things that we've connected on books and
helping others
and now you're helping me help other
kids so that
that makes me really happy jonah this
was our plan
all along to take care of people
together and the love of books
being at the forefront i love it i would
be honored i will help you i will be
there by your side whatever i can do
this is your endeavor
i'm just there to shine a light on it
and natalie
you and jonah have something in common
with libraries will you
tell us about the important endeavor
that you are embarking on
yes i'm i'm doing the um national
library
um associations benefit uh coming up
which is
so incredible libraries are of course
one of the
the model places of community um
one of the last places of community in
our in our country and places where
people can gather
people from all different classes
everybody is
um everybody is welcome it's one of the
last few
public meeting places and um
and resources of course because the the
the books the computers the uh
all of the the materials are available
to everybody
and um i'm so so honored to get to
to show my respect to them i was talking
to everyone here
just about how much i love your book
natalie and i like you
jonah i read it uh to my daughter so it
was really nice
to hear these famous fables that we know
so well
with a unique spin on it such as the way
you so beautifully write them natalie
um thank you and uh this is such an
elevated
timeless beautiful children's book and
it gave me such
pleasure reading it as an adult but my
children just got so much out of it
so thank you for writing it thank you
for putting it out into the world jonah
thank you
for reviewing it so thoughtfully and
jonah thank you you are
such an incredible young human you give
me so much hope for the future
thank you for what you just said i have
such respect for you natalie portman i
can't even believe i just heard what you
said
thank you um natalie and jonah you're
both just so wonderful thank you for
letting me be in this space today this
is like
what the world needs is both of your
energies natalie portman's fables
is out now
you